hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to
demonstrate how to flush a peripheral iv
before performing any nursing skills you
want to make sure that you're following
your hospital's protocols to ensure
you're following the latest guidelines
to flush the iv first what you want to
do is you want to gather your supplies
and perform hand hygiene so the supplies
you'll need to flush will be a saline
flush pre-filled one
you'll need a curos cap if that's
available
and you'll need an alcohol swab if
you're not using the keuros caps and
you'll want to don gloves so one of the
main purposes of flushing an iv is to
help keep this line patent because this
cannula is setting in you know blood and
a clot can form so we want to prevent
that from happening also you know we
flush an iv
whenever we are
about to give a medication and after
giving a medication
in between infusions and most hospitals
generally have a protocol where you
flush them every 12 hours so like every
shift but you always want to check your
facilities protocol and how they want
you to flush this
and
you may hear this referred to as a
saline lock all it is is it's saline
setting in this line hence it's locked
the line so
we don't have blood there to
have a clot form so then you would lose
your lime and you typically depending on
your facility are going to flush this
line with anywhere between three to five
cc's of normal saline and you're going
to use a push pause technique while you
flush this just helps give it turbulence
and clear that line out now one thing
that i want to point out is you want to
be familiar with what kind of supplies
your patient has especially the cap
because there's different types of caps
which dictate how you clamp like the
whole clamping sequence with flushing
and clamping and disconnecting so this
particular one that i'm using is by
baxter it's the one link it's a neutral
displacement fluid cap so
per the manufacturer's
recommendations there's no clamping
sequence but let's say that you're using
a positive pressure cap with that
you whenever you go to flush what you
would want to do is you flush then you
disconnect your syringe from the cap and
then you clamp but let's say you were
using a negative pressure cap with that
you would flush then you would clamp and
then you would disconnect so always just
be familiar with your supplies so to
flush the iv first what you want to do
is you just want to look at the site
make sure it looks good there's no
redness
ask the patient if it's painful if it's
painful that's not a good thing
do you see any like foul drainage or is
there any swelling
and make sure the dressing's nice and
clean and intact and then what you can
do is you can prep your flush so go
ahead open up your flush
and with these pre-filled syringes you
have to get the air bubble out so prime
your flush you're going to
twist this off
get the air out so what you want to do
first is if you are using the keuros cap
you um just make sure that it's been on
for one minute for it to be able to
disinfect the site so what you can do is
just twist that off and throw it away
and then you can just connect with your
syringe
if that wasn't the case let's say that
this cap was not there
what we would do is you would open up
your alcohol
swab
and you would take it
and you would go around on the hub
we're gonna like literally cover the
whole thing and we're getting on the
threads and everything and we're going
to
twist and we're going to clean
very rigorously
for about 15 to 30 seconds
and just twist and clean and it's very
important you do this because any germs
or bacteria that's on this can easily be
flushed into the patient system so take
your time to do that once you have done
that let that completely dry and then
i'm going to twist onto the cap
like this
and then you want to unclamp the site
because if you go to flush it then you
won't be able to because you'll meet
resistance and you just want to quickly
just check for blood return
and we've got blood return as you can
see and we're going to flush in about
three to five mls that depends on your
facility and we're going to do a push
pause technique as we flush so one to
two cc's paws one to two cc's
that just creates turbulence in there to
help flush that line out
and it's not swelling up or anything
you feeling any pain
okay and we flushed in what we need
because we're using a neutral cap we
don't have any clamping sequence so i'm
going to clamp
and then i'm going to remove discard
that for my facilities protocol and i'm
going to put on a fresh curos cap just
to protect the site and then i'm going
to doff my gloves perform hand hygiene
and document okay so that wraps up this
video and if you would like to watch
more videos on nursing skills you can
access the link in the youtube
description below